I will talk about data science at scale
only a ten minute so will be a very
general observation so today is very
easy the 200 gigabytes between your
fingers but it's you are well aware that
it is a big problem to do it in bundles
so this is the main topic of our
conversation a my name is Igor
Weinberger I'm a data scientist at the
R&D team in a very cyber intelligence
thing and I'm a lecturer in the course
of a data science bootcamp and daya and
sometimes you say this every
presentation is in fact an advertisement
so we have a new class of 30 13 very
highly is the people they are great
junior data scientist so if you are
interested please contact me after and
my talk will be mainly focused on what I
do in my day walk and which is you know
the intelligence usually avoids
aggravating a large amount of data and
then you are facing a problem that even
in the research stage you need all sorts
of support for my tea and everything
just to access the data and this problem
is very common you can even say today on
a Cargill
this is a list of the biggest data sets
in Cargill and you can see that some of
them are very large 80 bytes which is
most of the times you cannot fit it in
the under normal patter data frame and
one of the solutions that you have today
is of course using all of their scale
the solutions such as the spark and the
elasticsearch but these are often
involves you doing a lot of IT walk and
it's it's a lot of overhead
for very early research stages so I'm
very happy that after I tried a few
things I found the dusk which help you
deal with the two factors that are a big
problem today when you are analyzing big
data one of them is the problem that you
are unable to use the larger than memory
data set and the other is the speed of
execution which is using the parallel
mode so I think you probably well aware
of what is the basic problems of a using
a purlin name when you will have a
problem and they you can think of it as
a small little problems you when you
feel it without power lism to the
processor you got a bottleneck and this
caused their frustration a image where
you see the the notebook stuck but the
processor is not working at 100% and
today we are using most of the computers
have multiple curls and we want to
eliminate this bottleneck by paralyzing
the tasks so the basic building blocks
of said and ask for the parallelization
is the delay the object and I'm very
happy to do it right after the decorator
talk because you can use the decorated
and called delay and this can turn this
function into a delayed option object so
we have the simple increment function
and the simple edge function and what we
will do we will increment 15 put it in
eeks now unlike what you will normally
get when you are assigning ink in two
weeks you are not getting the value that
returns from the functions you are
getting a delayed object assigned to
this
variable and this same thing happens
when you do what is to I and where we
are applying the function for the two
delayed objects now we can get it into
total which you can probably assume that
is a delayed object so currently nothing
was calculated and in all of this cell
but what happened is the behind the
scenes they does created a direct a
cyclic graph computational graph it took
both of the implementation of our
increment function it placed it in the
today it faded to the add function and
they created that graph you can actually
get when you're using dusk you can get
this graph it can be very complicated
this is a very simple one that you can
get whatever graphs you're using and
they are the only thing that will have
will happen only once we use compute so
nothing will happen in the system until
we press away we give the computer
function this will produced and the
result to do so earlier now based on
this on this a delayed objects does get
built the three types of collection the
array which is parallel to nam pla the
which is them mostly for JSON structures
unstructured data and the data frame i
will focus on their data frame because I
think this is probably what interest
most of us so as you can see black we
saw in the earlier example the syntax is
very similar to the pandas s index if I
want to read it in a CSV I will just use
dusk a function of lithosphere we get
the train data frame so the cynic is
very similar but there is a big change
in it because once I pay I'll take the
dusk objects and apply shape to it I
will get the arrow and the arrow will
cause because we don't have a shape now
we only have the instructions of
placement of data in the delayed object
so the dusk is actually been used by a
chunk of data frames which are normal
data friends but on jumped we can
control these the sizes of the chunks in
there in the constructor and you can
choose them based on your system and
this will enable you to talk in very
specific size of the chunk that will not
include all of your memory so when it I
don't think you can see it right now but
when you say print type of the data
frame that they just loaded the type
with a data frame and if I want to get
the normal panda's data frame that I'm
used to it only thing I need to do is
just run compute on it and then I get
the type a planet called data frame just
a normal data frame but there are some
actions I can do without actually
loading all of it in one data frame to
the memory for instance I can use the
head function and get the top values and
is just a very short example of
something that you can do and cannot do
so this is a very simple passing of
string that is done in the upper case
for panel data frame and in here for the
desk data frame it is very similar but
it's big one difference when you want to
aggregate
number median then I'm sure some of you
are well that a median calculating it on
parallel it's much more complicated than
completely calculating the demean so
there are a few differences when you're
walking on a dust data frame that you
will have to endure in order to to keep
it all out of the memory so it does it's
not completely perfect but it is very
very strong a tool and it's very useful
when you are using it forward large data
sets so the in conclusion the dust is a
way is a a meant all to answer two types
of problem one of them is the powerless
rhythm and the other one is the an
ability that you have to load all of the
data into the memory now this is a very
nice graph that you can get just by
running the a desk distributed and
getting the localhost in the analysis
and you can see here that you can get
all of the tasks that are done based on
your your actions I'm sorry I don't have
the time to do a demo but this is the so
this is what you get when you are
running it does a lot of frame which is
very nice hi guys so I want to talk
about algorithms master stuff like that
but just something which can make your
life better without algorithms the idea
is that when you have a team of people
and each one of them working on a
project you would like to have some kind
of standard between them and I will tell
you why you need that and how can you do
that okay so this is the typical data
science team each one of them in
especially in like multidisciplinary
companies like in Gong so we have
totally different projects and each one
one of them on vision and computer
vision one of them on text and one of
them is on speech and each data
scientist works on another project and
you want some synchronization between
them since you would like one person to
over another project and so on and so
forth and usually each one has it their
own definition of what is the main
function and so on and where the data is
kept so it's really hard to get inside
in you next I would like to present the
solution which is called cookie cutter
it's not only for Python but there is a
special template which was already
created for Python so a cookie cutter as
the name suggests is a way to have a
template for a project and then you can
duplicate this template and create your
own project so the different project
will look more similar than random right
so like a when you have a a cookie
cutter like something with great
templates this is why it's completely
next so other people will thank you why
because they after a year they will go
and need to fix a bug in your code and
they will immediately understand the
structure and understand where are the
notebooks and where is the data and
where are the tests and where is the
training and where
models next you oh thank you because
sometimes the reading on code after year
is like reading someone else so you will
understand it will make you have better
practices of thinking as dark as a
separating between evaluation and an
test and dev sets and so on like and you
have to remember this templates not like
the cookie it's totally non-binding we
can always change it so if your project
has some special structure that you need
to get away from the
like the initial template it's okay you
can always change your project not to be
exactly like the template and moreover
like it's very flexible so you can have
both pre and post hooks to the creation
of the template so you can say once the
template the project is created do this
and that or before the project is
created do this and that and so it's
totally customer by customizable X so
it's very easy to start it's just a
Python package called cookie cutter you
just keep install it and watching you
install it you can run a cookie cutter
and then the name of the template the
way the place where the template is and
people already have hard for us so that
is an initial data science template over
there okay but you have to remember it's
only a suggestion for how should a data
science project look like if you don't
like it you can change it in gone we
have our own template you can create any
template you want and you can store it
in your git repository and instead of
using this template you can use another
template next so this is like the
initial suggestion for data science
template done others again is just a
suggestion and you can either use it or
use you on so
so how does it how does it look like
after you run the cookie cutter with the
with the template name it creates this
tree structure where is the the main
file it's called make file but it's not
really a make file it like for C where
you compile spiced stuff actually in
Gong we change it to be a Python code
because we wanted more flexibility of
what can you do but it is like the entry
point to the project
everything you do if you through this
this make files right make file download
data from s3 so this will download all
the data you've done need for your
project from last 3 or then make file
space train model and this will train
the model so every newcomer that wants
to know what are the possible functional
procedures or pipelines which exist in
the project they will just say next I'll
help them he or she will see all the
procedures that are available it can
also have the make file docker which
will create a docker for the project or
make file space environment which will
create a Anaconda environment for the
project so it can do whatever you
defined it to do another folder is there
a data folder which is automatically in
the beginning get ignored so the data is
not in github and they also offer some
differentiation between the raw data the
entering data the process data external
data actually we I believe all the names
of this folder disease but I did fall
follow the affected data is is a
separate in the project but ignored you
have the docs the models notebooks
references where you can put papers so
again you go into the project and you
don't remember algorithms that you've
used you already in github you know that
the paper will be
Frances you got a reports requirement
file which describe which packages
you've used and the source code okay so
again this is just suggesting you can
either follow it or extend it or delete
it and use your own template next I can
you go backwards again how much time do
I have
screaming okay so can you click this so
this is the project page here you can
read more about the logic behind the
cookie cutter and why is it important go
below please more more MORE until you
get to the video okay just play it in
maximum so this is demo how does it look
like
you just type cookie cutter name of the
template and need to ask you question I
forgot about that but you can define
parameters so every time you create a
new project it asks you questions like
what is your name what is the project
name with the s3 buckets that you use
for training and whatever questions do
you want it to ask and the answer to
those questions is actually injected
into the files or the folder structure
and so the name of the project will be
the name of the folder and in the readme
the title will be automatically the name
of the project and so on and so forth
so the parameters that you've entered in
this input stage will be injected into
the structure of the tree wherever you
want it okay
this clear okay and next slide please
so I would like to in the last minutes
of the talk Elizabeth about calm and
then then I will pass the mic to the
other person so going actually takes a
business the business call it's long
course not like when hot or telephone or
stuff like that call you which is b2c
but it
clunk oh when IBM sells a server to
someone and then in this cold it's
usually over meeting across across the
web so we have both video and audio and
in text and then we use the both
confusion and signal for sending speech
processing as anonymity to correlate
between what the cells indeed and may
what the performance of the sauce person
to understand what makes a good
salesperson or what should I bet
yourselves person do in order to be
better and if you're interested in
working with environment you can send us
an email
okay hi is my voice okay at the back
thank you so my name is Dahlia Gausman
I'm sponsored by cymatics
and I want to talk to you today about a
project called Thames a textural mess
solver which is the project I'm doing
for simplistic oh so simplistic oh is an
edgy tech startup company which operates
a website that functions as a private
math tutor so imagine you're struggling
with some function so what you can do is
go on the simplistic Oh website should
we have like a sign for when you can
push the thank you so imagine your
students struggling with some function
and what you can do is go on the website
enter your function into the online
calculator and what simplistic Oh will
do is they will guide you through the
process of solving the question and what
we're working on now is is to allow you
to also be able to interact with the
website in your natural language so
let's say I have ten minutes to talk and
I preferred forty two slides and I want
to know how long I can spend on each
slide then simplistic Oh will guide me
through the process of approaching this
kind of questions so what I want to talk
to you today
is one aspect of terms which reads the
question and then outputs the underlying
equation of the question obviously I
don't have 42 slides so we can all relax
and move on so I'm going to start by
touching a two key pre-processing steps
I'm going to do a short overview of the
neural network which takes the question
and extract the underlying equation then
I'm going to spend a moment about
results and then I'm going to share with
you why I think all of this is relevant
for all of us so we said I have the
question and let's before we go into the
details think about how we would
approach this problem general so imagine
you want to solve a textual math problem
probably you want a question to be in a
language that you understand if I give
you a sexual math problem in French and
you don't speak French there's not much
you can do about it so the same goes to
the machine I want to first translate
the question to a language that the
Machine understands next something that
I know from solving textual math
problems is that something good to start
with is replacing the numbers with
parameters and focusing only on the
structure of the question where later on
I could reintroduce the numbers into the
structure that I built so let's see how
I do that in two steps the first step is
the tokenization step which basically
means that I take the question I
separate it to its word sparse
takeaway punctuation and stuff and as I
mentioned every time I see a number in
the question I put it aside for later
use and I exchange it with a token of
the variable the next step is called an
embedding if what I'm doing is I'm
putting all the words that I have in my
corpus through words to vak algorithm
which what it does is it takes all the
words in my corpus and embed them in a
high dimensional space that preserves in
a way this nine
pick and pick tactic relationships
between the words so for instance my
embedding could pick up that counting
trees in a park is very similar to
counting slides in a talk and so if I
have this knowledge in my understanding
of the language and I've already seen a
couple of questions where I need to
count trees in the park the next time
when I see a new question that I've
never seen that asks me to count flies
in a talk I already know to apply the
same logic that I know that is relevant
for this kind of structure okay so I
will wrap up the previous part which we
took a question in the natural language
of the user and we transformed it to a
question in a language that the Machine
understands and we took the numbers
aside for for them for future use so I'm
going to you already have some buzz
words on the board
Tan's is a sequence to permutation
recurrent network with long short term
memory and attention which is a mouthful
but we're going to see it's not as
complicated as the title suggests so
let's break it down and see how it all
fits so we start we're starting with a
question the question is my input that's
the sequence and and the output is the
permutation and why would I want the
output to be a permutation because I do
expect that every number that I saw in
the question will appear in some manner
in the output equation so let's see how
I come how I arrived from the input
sequence through the output permutation
so as we mentioned the first part is I
want to translate the question from the
language that a user use this input to a
language that the Machine understands
the next question at the next part is
the recurrent neural network which is
the bulk part of this pipeline and in
this in this section
what happens is the machine reads the
words reads the question one word at a
time this is the short-term memory part
but it also reads every word in the
context in which it read that's the
long-term depart and the Ascension part
is where the system the Machine also
takes notice of the more important parts
in the question so let's say in the
beginning of that question I had another
sentence that said today I want to talk
at the PI data Meetup
this is obviously not so relevant for
the equation that I want to produce at
the end so I don't want to give it wait
so what the attention part does and this
is all inside this blue machine is takes
more notice takes more attention to the
more significant part of the question
now when I reach this part I'm pretty
confident that the machine has already
figured out the structure of the
question that it sees and now I'm ready
to introduce the quote the numbers that
I signed the question and hope that it
will arrange the numbers in the correct
way to produce the equation that
underlies the question now I chose to
use these large Lego blocks here because
a large part of the pipeline is affect
is relied on publicly accessible tools
developed by the community such as chaos
and word Zack and online resources such
as professional blogs and YouTube
channels and these are so I want to use
the stage to thank the community for
making this increasingly complex tools
increasingly accessible so thank you for
that so let's wrap up this pipeline we
saw that we're taking a question in the
user language and producing an equation
in mathematical form and what we can do
is what we normally do when we train
your
works is that we take many pairs of
question and equation and what we can
see that as the system sees more
questions more time it gets better
resolve really has a good way of
predicting the outcome equation and okay
maybe that's it so maybe now it's a good
time to wrap up what we have is a neural
network or actually a pipeline that
includes a neural network the takes that
was a spoiler but I forgive you that
takes a natural language sexual math
problem and produces an equation that
underlies the question in order to allow
some mystical to guide students in
solving the question and the major part
of the pipeline is made with public
publicly accessible tools which brings
me to my take-home message which is that
this is really an exciting time to be a
part of the data science machine
learning neural network community where
you can take practically any crazy idea
that you have in mind and if you know
the correct tools that are publicly
available and if you understand them
enough to integrate them together you
can really go as far as your imagination
thank you thank you so thank you one
question yes sorry how did I get data so
there are some tools that use a plastic
natural language processing tools to
tackle this problem the datasets are not
as large as I hoped when I first started
working on this problem but there is
some data from online resources and like
crawling some question and answers
website
thank you hi my name is Diane Chang I'm
a data scientist from Intuit also from
the California office and I'm pretty
jet-lagged so if I fall asleep halfway
through just drag me into a corner and
the next person can start so I'm talking
to you tonight about how we use a
technique called a rule ensemble map
it's a machine learning technique that
we use to help with our small business
lending so imagine that you own a small
business and you have a dream you want
to open a new location maybe it's the
first location maybe you're moving it
out of your house or your garage and you
need some money in order to do it
if you're like most small businesses in
the u.s. at least you would turn to your
bank as the place to go to try and get
some money but unfortunately most small
businesses get turned down we did a
survey and we found it in a two-year
period
60% of our small business customers had
applied for a loan and 70% of them were
turned down they on average submitted
three applications to three different
banks and spent about 33 hours filling
in those applications following up
questions and documents and so this is a
big problem for our small businesses and
go ahead and why is this important to
intuit well it into it we build
financial software for consumers and
small businesses and we want our small
businesses to thrive and so what one of
our involves our mission is powering
prosperity around the world and we want
our small businesses to prosper ok so we
have three different kinds of customers
and Intuit consumers the individuals
like you and me we have tax
professionals or accountants and we have
small businesses and we have products
for each of those different types of
customers but the one I want to focus on
is the small businesses our flagship
product for small businesses is a tool
called QuickBooks which is accounting
software and in it our small businesses
can enter all of their accounting
information like their invoices any of
their expenses
their assets all that information gets
entered into QuickBooks and then we have
another business on this side that we
call QuickBooks financing that helps
small businesses go ahead so the purpose
of QuickBooks financing is to help small
businesses get access to the money that
they need to help their businesses grow
and we know that accounting data can
help them they've already entered all of
the information into QuickBooks that the
lenders need in order to decide if
they're going to lend to them or not and
so with the customers permission we can
use that data to help them in the
lending process okay and so one of the
things we try and help our lending
partners determine which of our
customers are the most creditworthy and
to do that we're trying to predict
whether a small business would default
on a loan and typically when you're
trying to do a prediction problem like
this in the old days we used to build a
single model go ahead thank you so we
could build a big model like a decision
tree just one decision tree or we could
build a logistic regression but as most
of you know we're ensemble methods now
are preferred over building this type of
big model so instead of having one big
model dictator we actually have more
mock recei where we're building a lot of
little mock and vote and they together
determine what they is then outcome or
the answer will be and so the type of
ensemble method that we used for small
business lending is called a rule
ensemble and what do I mean by a rule
you can excuse me so these are some
examples of the rules that we build so
we're looking at characteristics of a
small business and we build rules that
are but you can sort of answer either
yes or no true or false and the question
that we have is well where do these
rules come from and that we use a
technique very similar to a lot of
ensemble methods we build decision trees
we build a lot of little baby decision
trees and from each of those decision
trees we generate the rules and so it
turns out that for every node in
a tree except for the root node every
node corresponds to a rule so as you can
see here the first branch corresponds to
the first rule the first the first
branch corresponds to the first two
rules I guess you could argue and then
as you go to the next level you get more
and more complicated rules and so from
one simple decision tree just a
two-layer to depth decision tree we've
already built six rules okay and so you
can imagine if we build a lot of little
decision trees how many rules were going
to get so now we're stuck with a lot of
rules and we have to figure out well
which of these rules are the most
important and we do that by assigning
weights to the rules so the rules
evaluate to a true or false of one or a
zero and then we wait each of the rules
so that if it's true the coefficient is
associated with that rule gets added to
our score and we build those and we
determine what those coefficients will
be using logistic regression so in the
way we're kind of combining those
traditional models that I was talking
about the decision tree and the logistic
regression and we're using the decision
trees to build the rules and then the
logistic regression to come up with the
waist for the rules and the form of
whether the rule ensemble looks like you
just are taking a direct sum of the
rules and as I said I didn't evaluate
either to a 1 or 0 and then the
coefficients are multiplied in menu add
them up and one of the great things
about doing this is that the decision
trees are really good at handling
categorical variables and a linear
regression is very good at having
continuous variables and in a way we get
the advantage of having both of them
with a rule ensemble because we get the
continuer the story the categorical
variables modeled really well by the
rules and then we can also add the
continuous variables here and have two
sets of coefficients that we're trying
to determine the A's that are the
weights on the rules and then the B's
are the weights on the continuous
variable okay and so this is a typical
kind of output that you would get from a
rule ensemble so the the far column is
the definition what the rule is
and then this middle column here is the
coefficient or the weight the the a sub
M so I was showing in the previous
slides and as you can see they could be
positive or negative so they might add
to our score or detract from the score
and then we have this column here that's
called the support or STD so if it's a
continuous variable it's the standard
deviation that's what the STD refers to
but if it's not if it's a rule they
recompute what we call the support and
the idea behind the intuition behind the
support is that you're trying to
understand how much this rule affects
the samples that you have so you look at
for each sample and you check to see is
what does the rule evaluate to true and
basically that means you're just adding
up that you're counting the number of
rules for which the the rule evaluates
or you're counting up the number of
variables of not variables of samples
for which the rule is true and then you
divide it by the number of samples you
have so you're kind of getting you know
an idea of the weight of how often that
rule evaluates to true and then we have
a final column sorry back up if I will
call them the importance and the
importance of a rule is determined by it
depends if it's a continuous variable
you look at the standard deviation and
you multiply it by the absolute value of
the coefficient but if it's a rule then
you look at the absolute value and the
coefficient and you multiply it by the
square root of the support times 1 minus
the support and so you can see if the
support is really tiny this value is
going to be small and it just means that
even though it might be a very important
feature if it doesn't affect very many
of your samples then it's not going to
be have that big of an impact in your
model and then if it is the other way
around if it's very close to 1 and it
impacts almost everything then again
it's not going to be a very
distinguishing feature of your model
okay and then from the importance oh I
forgot to mention you then just scale it
so you melt that you divide the
importance you figure out the importance
for every variable divided by the
maximum importance most
100 and then relative to that importance
and then from that you can compute the
importance of each of the variables or
features from your model and you do that
by if it's a continuous variable you
look at the importance of the continuous
variable itself plus you look at every
the importance of every rule that that
variable appears in and so if we were
looking at time in business and that
appeared in a rule with sales growth you
would divide the importance of that rule
by two because the time in business was
only half of the the impact because
there are two features in that rule and
then you add up the so you take the
importance of that rule divided by the
number of features in that rule and then
you add it up for all the rules where
the variable appears and so the reason
we chose to use real ensembles for its
small business lending is that they're
very easy to interpret and with lending
business in particular there are a lot
of regulations in the US about how you
can land and if you turn somebody down
you need to be able to tell them why you
need to be able to prove to a regulator
that you're not biasing based on a
protected category like gender and so if
the the models that you're using to make
these credit decisions have to be very
interpretive and they also handle
missing values very well it's part of
you know just being inherent part of a
decision tree one of your rules might be
that the value is missing and then it
easily incorporates both categorical and
linear features as I mentioned and then
it also has a strong predictive power of
an ensemble method that's it
[Applause]
one question so what doesn't change the
economy that's true so the question yep
yes there are definitely external
factors that affect the lending business
so the question was what what about the
economy and the economy definitely has a
huge impact on whether somebody defaults
on the loan but it does it doesn't so we
take that into account as well as more
of a global feature of how much risk
were willing to take on but when we're
trying to distinguish one company from
another we don't care as much about the
external economy but that's a good point
right thank you hi everyone I'm Tom and
today I'm gonna tell you a bit about to
build fast and powerful models with very
little data like mutation method so we
know data is the most crucial part of
our data mining in the AI application
exists and the next big is deep learning
so we know that in theory and an
algorithm have been around for quite
wherever the ability to process the
right amounts of data brought us to the
recent breakthrough in the field so
today I'm going to tell you not about
the pre-processing stage not about
cleaning data not about active learning
or semi-supervised learning I'm going to
tell you about augmentation doing a lot
of mutation is awesome
why do planning so we know that as the
amount of data increases the performance
is Grist as well so comparing to all
machine learning and computer vision
algorithm it's better for us to use deep
learning and now we I was wondering how
can we use data science techniques in
order to scale the amount of data that
we have
and what is the sufficient size for a
neural net to give an optimal
generalization anyone else who so
getting the data is not an easy task or
not some people use even other filters
or Mechanical Turk or CrowdFlower
but it's an headache because we need to
create a task and then you need to
validate the data that you get back
so the problem at hand is how can we
generate a large synthetic data from
small amounts of real data and how can
we still validate and have any eye
system to learn well on it why is it
good for us so who here is on Cabo
great so cargo we need the classifiers
all utilizing next to artificially
increase the number of the training
examples and we know that as the
algorithm is consistent like trees like
neural map at large the size of end of
the training set the smaller the
generalization training set consists of
independent draws from the same line
distribution can keep the wiki drawing
as long as you want and then we
construct a training set as much at
large
lastly data mutation can act as a
regulator and prevent overfitting in
your network what are the use cases we
can use for augmentation so the ancient
balance class problems it's the it's the
best case to use it other case arm would
be testing and validation and and the
other one is overfitting and lastly
images to make the network invariant to
certain transformations such as
translations sleep and so on
so the challenge is that sometimes we
don't have prior knowledge on the data
set of heads if you have a task that you
already know it's an error the task is
then it's easier to augment your data
however sometimes you don't know what
your data at hand you even don't have
any ground truth the feature might vary
from time to space from one application
to another and people try to use for
instance resampling methods such as
bootstrapping so on and so forth but
it's not really working so there are
three spaces you could think about data
augmentations 2d images 1d and video the
easiest space is of course images you
could think of of an image and then
augment your data set and originally the
day of warping was used in order to
balance the amount of training examples
for each character class and a
handwriting task and we know the data
augmentation can reduce the bias in the
classifier to favor more frequently
presented training examples how can we
create additional training examples two
definitions one data P which generate
additional sample search information
apply to the air space the other one is
a synthetic over sampling which create
additional samples in the feature space
the elastic deformation is to create
augmentation in the data space by
defining the word random displacement
field in the images and specified a unit
display vector there are two other
algorithms as found in the augmentation
in the feature space
the first one is most fair
for the synthetic minority of a sampling
technique and the second one which is
more complicated it's the density based
mode algorithm for the experiments or I
conducted a classification architecture
that was divided into two stages the
first stage included the future
generation and the second one is the
classification stage then I was
wondering what's better is it better to
conduct data augmentation in the data
space or is it better to feature space
iucn and i try to perform to actually
work with with Emily's and I discovered
the following I discovered it was better
to perform data Commendation in the data
space I thought actually it was better
to do it in the feature space but it's
better to do it in a data space as long
as the label preserving transformation
unknown and the smooth algorithm can be
used to perform data element ation in
the feature space it's more about
solution the DB's mode algorithm can
increase overfitting due to the
algorithm creating these samples close
to the existing clusters and this proved
the improvement in the error provided is
actually busted by the equivalent amount
of the river for the implementation alex
karras api it's pretty straightforward
now I move through to another space the
1d space and then I the only thing I
need to keep in mind is that the
characteristics over the small data set
I must get
I must actually don't destroy them and
it's very very challenging because the
vector is the feature they might be
binary might be numerical might be
categorical I don't really know what are
the correlations of the covariance
matrix between those vectors and I
actually need to verify what what are
the scholarly
in the covariance so I came up with
three algorithms that surely of out of
the sky I'll actually describe two of
them in the next slide the first one is
a based on GMM including the be IC score
the second one help it's based on M the
second one is the k-means clustering I
also use this you well measures in order
to augment the clusters the third mode
which I won't cover here is actually a
more complicated algorithm where I
measure all the covariance matrix by Chi
square test and a Marshall information
test and I also use a square so in a
nutshell I'll just describe the
two-stage architecture so the first
stage is fit a clustering model you
choose a class with model IVA GMM of
k-means then we adapt the methods for
the part and the parameters to the shape
of the data then we select the number of
clusters and then we select other
parameters using a clustering metric in
the second stage is the sampling you
random some you random the cluster and
then you generate data using random
samples from the cluster enhance the
data so as I mentioned the data can vary
behave differently from one just case to
another and I came up with different
cases where the datasets were pretty
different one another it might contain
numerical categorical binary vectors it
could tell missing values it all and
also I might not have count
specification or any prior knowledge
about the data which is sometimes hard I
try to my algorithms with three data
sets the first one in sleeping patterns
wired data from the Fitbit the second
one is the medical data and another one
is the IOT data of air conditioning so
vocal gluten augmentation advantages
first of all increase your data set side
as much as you want
second of all the model is more robust
and you actually can prevent overfitting
with 2d space augmentation is better in
the data space and its provide greater
benefit for improving performance and
reducing overfitting the GMM based
clustering and model actually produce
diverse result it might be a bit it
might be tricky because sometimes you
get values which are not good if you
have values that are near zero value if
I compare it to the k-means you might
get sampling that produce result that
are not as diverse as the GMS based
algorithm however the boundaries of the
data are respected thank you very much
[Applause]
so actually and the data space
augmentation is very similar with what
you mentioned but the vector there is
normalized by a strength parameter so
it's like I guess it's more robust way
to do it but I guess it's more of the
same so sometimes you cannot use you
cannot actually estimate the density of
the data you have a data set where you
have missing values and you don't really
know how can you and what is the density
so
[Music]
I'm trying to project it to another
space and then I'm trying to find from
multiple models what is the best model
that fits and then I try to sample from
the best cluster just by the number of
samples in the cluster okay awesome
thank you yeah great question so the
classification stage it's actually a way
for me to measure what is what is the
performance of the first augmentation so
part so what I do I actually compare it
to to the data set without documentation
this is one way a second way is actually
to train a classifier that knows how to
predict in augmented data versus real
data and then if it works well it means
that you didn't do a good job but if the
classifier doesn't really know how to
predict what is it augmented data then
it seems like you did a good job